Mày 2,5 năm hành hủ chom 2 mì sấu, tông tin từ công an tình lọc kai. Đân vị đã bắt sự đổi tưởng gây ra vụ an giết người,
cứ tài sản đặc biệt nghiên trọng sử ra tại thương quy khủng, sát xun ảy tình lọc kai.
Chứ đó, khoảng 18 giờ ngày mì tán tháng 1 năm hành hủ chom 2 mì sấu, chỉ trình thí hát, sinh 1,5 yên trình trăm tấm i ba,
và con gái là vụ an tê, sinh 1 hành hủ chom mi chính, đến sát xun ảy để xem đàn lượng ngô về bán si tết như sau đó mất liên lạc.
Qua chính sát mình, tình kiếm đã phát hiện chỉ hát tử vong tại khu vực đổi quyết, thuộc thôn quy khủng,
sát xun ảy, chau tê bị tương nặng đăng bất tình gần đó, đưa đưa đi cấp cứu.
Để khoảng 18,8 mì phút cùng ngày, các lượng đã bắt sự đổi tưởng gây án là phụ tinh cao, sinh 1,5 yên trình trăm tình mi chính,
chú tại thương quy khủng, sát xun ảy.
Tại các khoảng cạnh rất đều tra, đối tượng khai nhận, rất thử tình tiêu sài,
sáng có một quyết và đã tưởng giữa thử chí hát đi một lợt ở trên địa bàn sát xun ảy và lần lên đánh này sinh ý định lời chỉ hát xung xát xun ảy để thực hiện thành viết người.
Cứ tài sản, chung ai bị tạm thắm 1 năm hành hủ chăm 2 biệt sấu, phung tinh cao để thoại hành tập chỉ hát ở đối linh thương tục thôn quy khủng về giấn đi xem đàn lợt.
Số đó, đối tượng đường nạn nhân đi lên khủng bật đối quyết, tình công xí hát khiến nạn nhân tử vong tại chỗ,
chào tê bị thương nạn sau khi về an, đối tượng đã cúp xe máy và một chứ bị thạc của nạn nhân dồi bỏ chủ khỏi hiện chương.
Hình vụ việc đang được phong cạnh rất hình sự công an tình lọc kai tiếp tục đều tra,
sử lý theo quy định của pháp lột.